so here's my prologue right I'd like you
to consider the line with this equation
okay now when you first met like oh how
many years ago now when you first met
these linear equations the only wait
like you didn't know that three was
going to be the gradient and you didn't
know that negative one was going to be
the y-intercept you didn't even really
have language for that right we
developed it afterwards what did you do
to graph this thing to know where it was
going you use the table of values and
then you use that to plot points let's
draw up a quick table values won't take
long
let's do um let's take three values on
their free will be enough
so for instance a pretty simple set of
values might be like maybe negative 1 0
& 1 that'll that'll give us some
certainty there so if I have those X
values let's just quickly mentally
compute this as a very simple function
so we should be able to do this if x
equals negative 1 when you input that
water you get 4 y minus 4 right because
you got minus 3 minus 1 when x is 0 you
minus 1 which is 1 and when x equals 1
you got 3 take away 1 which is 2 okay so
now I have it if you're happy with that
and I could graph this ok
I could say that this means minus 1
minus 4 should be on that line all right
this one and this means one should be on
that line are you okay with that all
right now this is the way we normally
did this but now I'll be reversed okay I
want you to imagine that we had it's
this table of values something different
let me show you now this is all I gave
you right and a lot of this stuff which
I just showed you you were not aware of
like for example you didn't know this
equation right and you didn't have this
table values which I've only used so we
get these numbers and you see where they
come from
okay if all you saw with these three
lines okay you can see they're all in
the same format right they all follow
the same kind of pattern okay they're
all in this something some number over
here equals three times another number
take away one they're all in the same
format okay we're looking at these three
equations okay we're looking at these
three here's what I want us to write
down because this is like the key part
of the logic in the proof this guy right
which literally just goes by and you're
like what just okay so we're gonna write
it down write these equations right
these equations are all in the same form
they're all in the form now we're going
to put some labels on this right we
already have labels up here so we might
as well reuse them these equations are
all in the form y equals 3x take away 1
right I put in Y an X there because
these numbers are changing they are
variable right where
is the three and the minus one they are
constant so they just they're always
there every single time right but not
only are they in this the particular
values for x and y because they're
always paired up right I can write them
in this way I can say well this X and
this Y are paired up right so the normal
way I would pair up an x and y are in
writing coordinates that's how I write
this right so these are all in the form
y equals 3x minus 1 4 negative 1
negative 4 which is this guy in the form
0 negative 1 which is this guy and in
the form 1 2 which is this guy yeah say
it again
x equals 2 yes yeah it absolutely could
be and then all of my points would be
yeah just flipped that's that's all it
would be I would then say it'd be minus
4 minus 1 and minus 1 0 and 2 1 and you
would get the inverse of that it still
satisfies the equation right so in some
ways it's just being convenient for me
ok so now that I'm saying all these
equations are in this form for this set
of points what that means is this is the
equation that goes through all of those
points ok this is like the converse of
saying if these satisfy this then
they're on there I'm trying to say it in
the other direction right I'm saying
this satisfies all of these therefore
this must be the line that passes
through all of them does that make sense
to see that logic it's a converse we
don't use converse is that often which
is why when we pull that out for the
caller it's a little bit hmm
eyebrow raising ok so make sure that's
written especially if you just walk back
how am I going to find the equation of
this court of contact okay well the
first thing that we know is it depends
on these tangents doesn't it right
that's why we drew the tangents in so
the first most common sense thing to do
is find out the equation of this tangent
an equation of that tangent conveniently
I already know a form that tells me the
equations of the tangents right away ok
so the first thing I'm gonna say is the
tangent na right because I've named it
x1 y1 this is
exactly the equation of that tangent cuz
there's X 1 and there's y 1 okay so I'll
just write that down here there's the
equation of the first tangent right the
left-hand one the equation of the second
tangent will look almost identical with
what difference yeah there'll be two
instead of one right it's gonna be X X 2
2 a y plus y 2 okay now the other thing
I know about these tangents is they're
not just random tangents they're both
intersect down here at the same point
actually that's where they came from
right that's where we drew them from
right so if both tangents pass through
this point then this point should
satisfy both these equations are you
satisfied with that so I should be able
to put X naught Y naught into both of
these and that should be true say the
true statement okay so since both pages
pass through pain okay but rewrite both
subjects naught y naught X naught Y
naught okay so it's going to look like
this I've taken both tangents for which
I have this convenient form just to
straight away spit out the equation of
those tangents I don't underneath this
form anymore
okay I've used it up I've noticed that
both tangents pass through P that's kind
of a point of those tangents X naught Y
naught so since they pass through there
I can substitute X naught Y naught into
both equations and it should be true
okay all right now from this line is
pair of lines I'm going to rearrange it
ever so slightly ever so slightly right
I'm going to do swap terms here watch
I'm gonna write it like this now you may
well be asking what was the point of
that like it almost looks identical just
some numbers have shuffled around okay
and the reason why this is
valuable is because this is exactly what
we did right here do you see this
remember add questions and the same
format okay they add these threes in
common and they all minus ones in common
you see that okay now you have a look at
this pair of read equations look at the
pair of read equations you've got an X
in the same spot you've got a 2a in the
same spot and then you've got a y naught
in the same spot what has changed is
this pair of values at the front and
this pair of values nestled in here okay
that is what has adjusted okay
so how could just like I ruin out y
equals 3x minus 1 I wrote that off the
basis of these equations I took 3
equations in the same format and I
fashioned for myself an equation that
would generalize those right these are
three specific examples but this is the
generalization of those three so I want
to do that for here right what would
that equation look like well I know that
these three things I've underlined in
green they should all be the same right
so I should have an X naught or
something X naught equals to a outside
of something plus y naught now what goes
in those spots well in the first thing
it's whatever x-coordinate you want
right it's an x-coordinate of some
variety so I'm gonna write X that's the
variable it's very you can see x1 x2
they change around what goes in here
it's a y-coordinate of some description
right which also varies okay so I'm
going to write Y there because it's the
Y variable okay this here is the
equation of the chord of contact and
right now you should be looking at that
and sort of blinking and thinking
DejaVu just turn back to the first
things you wrote this morning what's the
equation for the Cartesian equation I
should say for a tangent at x1 y1 I mean
I even have it on the board right it's X
x1 equals to a y plus y1
that's the equation of the Tanner and
then you look at the equipment with the
court of contact and it's exactly the
same but with a zero instead of a 1
because the zero is off the parabola and
a 1 is on okay now crazy this is weird
okay but we shouldn't be that surprised
right remember again turn back I rubbed
it off so I'm gonna have to rewrite it
when we write we could a chord has this
equation right and when you do those two
points that form the chord a prototype
converge its chord you get a tangent
right and you get this guy okay well if
this is a chord and you bre-x a chord
sure enough turns into a tangent the
difference is that here you've got two
parameters and the two parameters become
identical right whereas yeah you've
quoted that off the parabola and it
turns into a point that's on the
parabola that's the only difference
there is now if you're like me right
you're still kind of hmm I'm not totally
sold okay you need to see it so let me
show you